ми стенд ось один ще я козир хоч і км
від і девід боуї сказавши в інтерв'ю ми
ж 20 роки в тому дпр приватно
колекції рок зергів porsche посту на
передачі ним а публікою аукціон їмо
сотбі виставити на продаж моєї ж 400
об'єктив із колекцією
алоді teuа набридне його до пройдисвіту про
і шкіряних по бачаті 1000 треба
холодними на десять рук і все
гарантії давай все на свою колекцію
ланцюги три mavala і обкласти тему науки ра
і знайти міша часті на колекції
складається з 200 50t зображення
скульптур вигідних британських мотив
пілоти відтінити мільйони з рідних ви
двору демієна херста якова бога та його
стиснувши сперечатися цю шию і амебіазу
задумані карти на 1995 руку всі роботи
писав і так полотно портал і бризок дуже
на нього pharma sa заклала вигляд і
підковок 1000 без контролю і я гадаю
боуи batch схожість між м як створе
волосся cm природи та агенство ріа в
свою музику у ванній на місяць c1 за
улюблених картин голий принц для франка
ауербаха співак сказав хочеш щоб моя
музика була схожу на всю картину червоною
перлина та колекції поважається робота
нью-йоркського повстяного художника
жан-мішель баскія її стягнути у три з
половиною мільйона фунтів стерлінгів
крем картин то скульптурно продажів так вже
виставляти колекцію дизайнерських
предметі бога і сам не піду на піну
скаже б поза викраденням було груші та windows
та ціни купивши знайти call його вся би ми
засобом аліцин і так гадаю на витік
гвин був без хачин que pase que піки в
каші nevian судно зебра гуте колекцію
хоч би виглядав і стиву руду на валу я
вишила судова ці предмети і кемал і
довгих особливого значення а ларі що він
його вирішив 1 вистачає кольору
виставку можна допомогти це в Лондоні до 9
серпня далі у планах
Лос-Анджелес Нью-Йорк це гонконг
аукціон ви будете британською столицею
галуст впади